as you walk into the night management
center and you look to the left you'll
notice the cornerstone of the center
with an inscription that reads dedicated
to the things that haven't happened yet
and the people who are going to dream
them up and i love that inscription
because to me it so completely captures
the essence of what the GSB is about
which after all is innovation and it
speaks to our two-fold mission on the
one hand is the creation of the ideas by
the faculty integrate research
university which will inform the
practice of management on the other hand
that portal is a portal to generations
of students who will enter the complex
and begin a process of personal
transformation a process that will
enable them to dream up those things
that haven't happened yet and through
that to change lives change
organizations and change the world in
the curriculum we start with what we
call perspectives we deal with issues
like ethics strategic leadership and the
global context of management these are
the core concepts that a leader who's
looking at how to take their
organization forward has to be familiar
with we also then do a deep dive into
what we call foundations this is the
nitty-gritty of the basic management
skills and knowledge that any leader of
a managed organization has to master
we're talking about finance operations
marketing and so on but to really change
the world you have to know how to lead
and we think that that involves three
essential capabilities firstly you need
to be able to understand what the
problem is so that's where critical
analytical thinking comes in then you
need to think about what the solution is
well that's where innovation comes in
finally you have to be able to take that
and implement it and that's where
personal leadership comes into effect
our approach of critical analytical
thinking is pretty unique we start with
a very intimate seminar in the full
quarter in that seminar we look at some
pretty interesting issues for example
what's your google do in China and we
look at the HP Board's decision around
Markovitz resignation but what we're
really doing beyond our focus on the
issues is teaching our students about
argumentation personal
leadership starts with self-awareness
and then it is about how you interact
with others there are a couple of things
that are distinctive and unique about
our approach one builds on a long legacy
at the GSB which is the course on
interpersonal dynamics known to many as
touchy feely the other is coaching
helping them to learn through skills
based exercises how to be effective
leaders the third capabilities
innovative thinking here we're moving
aggressively to try to incorporate some
of the learnings we've gotten from
working with the design school around
innovation an example of the kind of
collaborative work that we've done there
is Jim patel's course on entrepreneurial
design for extreme affordability we're
tremendously excited that this personal
transformation is going to have a new
home in the knight Management Center
which opens in the spring the knight
Management Center has eight buildings
arranged around three quads with a wide
variety of space that's quite different
from what we have now more flat
classrooms more breakout rooms and we're
going to have a colab which is a garage
like space where the students are going
to be able to roll up their sleeves and
do innovative new projects in an actual
hands-on way we envision a space that is
very collaborative a space for students
get together around a table to dream up
the next business plan the way Phil
Knight did while he was at the business
school it is really a home for
innovation as the knight Management
Center approaches completion I really
want to thank you for all of your
contributions great and small which have
made this possible and I look forward to
your continued participation in the life
of the school whether it's as a mentor
as a volunteer coming back for your
reunion or as a donor thank you so much
for being part of the life of the school
and for everything that you do for us if
you really want to see the impact on our
students please click on the link on the
page where you'll read some quotes from
our students who describe their own
personal transformation